[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont là trois chanteurs anglais
déguisés pour le playback dans une
seconde elle sourit kaboul n est autre
que freiner mercurey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et encore
je vais
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
kaboul est la seule artiste à jouer de
dos
1 parce qu'il a fallu lui faire des
grands signes pour le dire mais toi face
à la caméra que l'on puisse amortir ce
déguisement minable d'un ton désabusé et
la lassitude et les vitesses
mesdames et messieurs john lennon n'est
autre que john mitchell mer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wen
oui
[Applaudissements]
elles savent et en plus ça fait double
usage c'est à la fois john lennon et la
pub pour chaussée aux moines et là c'est
le clou du spectacle la cerise sur le
gâteau aux cherry choc de cake elton
john
mais non
[Musique]
c'est pas là
c'est même un émoi immédiatement le nom
de l'assistant qui lui a fait trois ans
qu'il fallait faire gilbert montagné
mais quel est le rapport avec le jeu n'a
jamais sauté alors regardez en plus il
va faire un fournisseur direct c'est
tyson jones était elton john ah oui tu
connais pas un tube delton je vaux
[Musique]